[Musique]
il
et
amical
[Musique]
mais
sachez que dans mon ma commune tout le
monde le sait que je suis gilet jaune
y en a marre de toutes ces états y en a
marre de toutes ces augmentations
faillites augmentent tous les jours ils
nous pondent quelque chose de nouveau
alors qu'il ya des gens en gilet jaune
dehors qui se battent pour tous les
averses
voilà moi ça me gonfle
au départ moi je me suis engagé rapports
déjà simplement parce que on vit pour
avoir une justice juste social justice
pour que les gens puissent puisse vivre
manger à leur faim
avoir un toit c'est pour toutes ces
injustices transvaal
[Musique]
ensemble ils ont traversé les saisons
pour lydie et ses camarades la
résistance s'est écrite sur un
rond-point un samedi après l'autre ils
ont appris à se connaître de tous âges
et de toutes classes sociales
ils font entendre la voix des citoyens
au début on n'ose pas trop y aller et là
quand je suis arrivé sur place
finalement il ya plein d'autres que je
connaissais de l'usiné où mon mari
travaille entre autres et tout donc je
n'étais pas perdue quoi je veux dire
voilà on s'est regroupé on a discuté
tous qui après on a fait des tournées
points voilà et c'est parti là dessus
quoi ensemble ils racontent une france
qui souffre
le prix de l'essence fut le déclic de
leurs engagements mais très vite comme
partout en france les manifestants de
plus en plus nombreux appelaient à une
justice fiscale et sociale partout sur
les routes de la région
les blocages se multiplièrent
[Musique]
on est à 2 à père a travaillé lui a
travaillé mon pays
chose que mon dernier comme taxes on
n'en peut plus moi la fin du mois on est
toujours à moins quelque chose dedans
que matheron salah
avec ses financiers on sera là aussi
sur mon poids je vois plein de gens qui
travaillent et puis qui s'en sortent pas
dit s'ils sont vraiment dans la misère
on voit même dans les grandes
souffrances les chariots en début de
mois puis en fin de mois c'est pas
pareil ou le monde dans les grandes
surfaces 1 les gens ils ont à pays vont
les cacher nous le dise ah ben voilà
c'est la fin du mois on va avoir du
monde ou à ben non là le 15 du mois
voilà on attend le client de toute façon
faut pas rêver et puis beaucoup de gens
retraités et tout pour qui je travaille
c'est pareil ils comptent tous quoi ils
comptent tous dans la salle je pense que
le pouvoir d'achat
ces dernières années a énormément baissé
[Musique]
on continuera le combat parce que
on peut pas nous le peuple et il est
dans la misère on est tous là dans le
même but c'est que notre pouvoir d'achat
notre vie soit meilleur c'est tout ça
aberrant alors on dit les pays ceci les
pays cela la malnutrition et tout mais
il n'y a pas besoin d'aller je veux dire
tu fais trois kilomètres autour de toi
tu en as tu peux les compter en a 10 de
gens qui sont qui se nourrissent mal qui
on a un monsieur qui avait pas de
chauffage
il faut absolument que ça change parce
que là les gens en ont vraiment marre
en ce début d'année 2010 9 de nouveaux
visages investissent les ronds points
les femmes montent au front et de toutes
leurs voix dénoncent la précarité de
leur vie maintenant on a peut-être du
souci à se faire s'ils sortent de leur
cuisine de leur bureau activement la
persévérance elles ont investi les rues
de montceau-les-mines nevers dijon ou
autant l'écho des femmes résonne un peu
partout dans la région et donne aux
mouvements des gilet jaune une couleur
inédite
moi je suis là pour les futurs il faut
penser aux prochaines générations
ça se bat pas maintenant c'est fini si
les femmes sont dans la rue c'était un
message encore plus fort derrière c'est
que peut-être de leurs enfants n'ont pas
trop d'avenir et qu elle le sent bien
tout ensemble elles se dressent pour
défendre l'avenir de leurs enfants leur
marche pacifique sont à la mesure de
leur détermination
pendant ce temps là il y en a quand même
qui se gavent y en a qui sont en même au
soleil doigts des pieds en éventail py
qui touchent des dividendes des actions
des machins c'est vraiment gonflant quoi
vais je pense que les gens s'en rendent
compte
mais ils ont peut-être pas le dire
vraiment ben faut pas qu'il faut qu'ils
ouvrent oser oser
toute la vie c'est un combat patrons ne
lâchent pas au moins trois tirs plus
tard moi j'ai essayé
donc on continuera en outre à des idées
on va y arriver
boko qui vient pas parce qu'ils sont
maçons abu jamal gens qu'on a d'elle
c'est vrai qu'on est une famille on est
des familles on est pacifiste mais ça
commence à être fatiguant une chose
garder le rond point jeanne rose en tant
que pacific garder cet esprit familial
parce qu'on en a besoin
faut vraiment qu'on se soutienne qu'on
garde ce côté de soutien sabrina revient
de loin
à 37 ans mère de deux enfants elle s'est
engagée dans le mouvement des gilet
jaune comme on joue sa vie chaque
semaine elle retrouve ses camarades dans
une salle communale à montchanin ont des
bas des actions futures et on partage
ses difficultés
sabrina a choisi de sortir de l'ombre
pour faire entendre la voix de toutes
les femmes précaires
comme j'avais précisé j'ai été invité au
sénat en tant que femme en tant que pour
la journée de la femme c'est ma vie
c'est mon parcours c'est pas passé à
présenter sabrina a été choisi par
l'association femmes solidaires pour
venir à paris devant les sénateurs
elle a témoigné du combat quotidien de
nombreuses mères de famille
[Musique]
donc voilà j'ai appris que j'ai beaucoup
souffert dans la vie sa fille ça fait
bizarre et sa parole la manie s'est
parlé la petite d'hommes avec son fils
donc bonjour tout le monde je m'appelle
dominique j'ai 41 ans et je suis maman
célibataire d'un petit garçon qui va
voir neuf ans comme la dame s'était
exprimé tout à leurs problèmes de
pension alimentaire non payés j'ai un
jugement d'octobre 2010 est où le pape a
été condamné et donc il paie pas la
pension alimentaire
mais en février et en mars j'avais 860
euros pour vivre avec mon fils et comme
madame non six avaient besoin de basket
mais malheureusement je pouvais compter
que sur moi même donc bah mon enfant est
obligé d'attendre de moi parce que je
pouvais pas faire autrement et la
justice et bah je suis en colère parce
que bas concernant les pensions
alimentaires les bons des payeurs et
tout sa part on s'en fiche et voilà
[Applaudissements]
donc quelle république vivons nous c'est
une question de conscience peut-on
aujourd'hui accepter le départ se
retrouvent dans ces situations là pour
nous c'est intolérable
la douceur des paysages cache bien des
détresses les campagnes se vident tandis
que de plus en plus de familles plonge
dans la pauvreté des femmes jeunes qui
vivent seules avec leurs enfants mais
aussi des retraités dans les maigres
pensions ne suffisent plus pour vivre
[Musique]
derrière la belle image d'une bourgogne
viticole et touristique
c'est un autre visage de la région qui
apparaît la mobilisation des gilet jaune
a révélé combien les inégalités
progressent peu à peu les langues se
délient
on nous laisse nous abandonnons
s'abandonner il ya un truc qui marche
pas on a vraiment faim en france on a
faim on n'en peut plus on n'a plus rien
à donner rendez compte que dans le
budget est le budget essence
c'est ce qu'on va pas manger on se prive
des fois de de s'offrir le luxe de
s'acheter un rôti un rôti de boeuf
moi ça me donne l'eau à la bouche c'est
ou leur petit boeuf ou les sens je fais
quoi j'ai toujours travaillé
quoi qu'il arrive toujours j'ai pas
envie de déjà de donner une image à mes
enfants de quelqu'un à la maison qui
profitent de la société qui profite de
tout ça non
tour à tour serveuse responsable de
magasin est fonctionnaire dans la police
sabrina a multiplié les expériences
professionnelles
mais l'apparition d'une maladie il y a
deux ans a changé le cours de sa vie
elle a dû s'arrêter de travailler au
restaurant qui l'employait tandis que
s'éternisait la procédure administrative
pour reconnaître son handicap pour
sabrina et ses deux filles
ce fut la dégringolade
[Musique]
il a safer deux ans que vivre avec 500
800 euros par mois c'est très compliqué
la fin de contrat ge s'est retrouvé gay
mois à peine 300 euros pour vivre ça a
été à se poser la question je fais quoi
de plus de 300 euros
je paie mes factures je mange ou je paye
mes soins je me suis retrouvé à pleurer
dans les bras de ma fille ma grande qui
me dis qu'est ce qu'il ya j'y arrive pas
parce qu'ils veulent vendre qu'acheter
des yaourts je peux même pas jeter
yaourt acheter une baguette de pain
c'est en garde le portefeuille a même
plus un centime
si la survie on vit pas on survit
moi mon engagement dans dans le gilet
jaune c'est comme une leçon de vie suez
fille me disait tout la grande m'a dit
tu nous fatigues et petit lait gilet
jaune
on n'en peut plus elle me réclamait
j'essaie de leur faire comprendre que je
fais ça pour elle aussi
je suis heureux dit en compte sharon
s'il m'arrive quelque chose tu fais quoi
tu veux te retrouver à la rue tu veux
galéré tu veux vivre ce que je vis je
suis maman combat c'est c'est pour que
tes des droits plus tard pour que tu
connaisse pas ce que je vis pour que
plus tard si tu tombes malade puisse
avoir accès à des soins pour que tu
puisses continue-t-il études je fais ça
pour que nos jeunes aient une vie plus
simple plus tard
[Musique]
en s'engageant dans le mouvement sabrina
s'est relevée sur cette terre de
bourgogne marqué par des années de crise
les femmes ont décidé de faire face
[Musique]
au fil des mois l'histoire de sabrina de
lydie et de leurs camarades a rejoint
celle d'autres rond point
[Musique]
et c'est une même chanson qui traversent
maintenant les territoires aux quatre
coins de france résonne la voix des
femmes qui se sont mises en marche sur
la route qui mène à beaune se fait
entendre une drôle de troupes tout de
jaune draper
les marcheurs sont partis de marseille
il y a trois semaines et font route vers
paris
ils marchent au nom de la justice
sociale et fiscale
vous avez un bon passeur robinho c'est
fiable franchement tu le gagnes en
arrivant on vient et chanter les
poignées tout pout pout comme tout au
long des cinq cents kilomètres déjà
parcourus
sarah manon nathalie et leurs camarades
seront hébergés ce soir chez l'habitant
ramène ta staff va bien donc du coup ce
soir ça se vit comme ans pour qu'on les
couches c'est soit 8,20 francs et vite
suite comme ça dit enrichi toi s'agit
donc qui est au dessus qu'elle tombe à
d'abord donc du coup s'il famille
l'empruntent guet-apens françois ci soit
x 8 et 2 10
jadis donc oui il me restait 6 a touché
la ville et le petit déj du matin
aujourd'hui c'est marie la bourguignonne
qui organise l'accueil des marcheurs
elle a réussi à obtenir qu'ils soient
tous reçus à leur arrivée en mairie de
beaune sait tous on a besoin comme abel
ça va ça va ça va je suis contente
d'entendre ta voix moi j'ai quelques
petites questions à poser pour ce soir
si tu peux me répondre est ce que tu
pourrais demander qu'est ce qu'ils
mangent des escarres pièce qui mangerait
des escargots
[Musique]
donc je suis personnes qui mangeaient
escargots et donc du coup vous allez
arriver à combien vous êtes combien
l'assureur sur le suroît de groupes là à
vous êtes 19
parce que celle nous avait dit que vous
étiez 15 et donc du coup la ya quatre
personnes deux puisqu'ils sont avec vous
c'est ça d'accord vous êtes 19 donc il
faut qu'on vous couche à 19 ça marche
donc ça et donc oui moi toute façon se
débrouillera t'inquiète pas donc moi
j'ai prévu que toi tu dormais chez moi
du coup d'accord quand zaba sera plus
imposant pour avoir un peu c'est
d'acheter un gros bisou plein de courage
pour la fin de la marche qui d'un
vivement ce soir que vous avez
évidemment
leur marche citoyenne est un acte de
résistance
c'est aussi pour eux une manière
d'interpeller le gouvernement autant que
les habitants et les élus de chaque
région qu'ils traversent
[Musique]
on voit que les gens sont super mobilisé
deux partout avant de créer un avenir
meilleur pour tous ce soir les gilet
jaune sont les bienvenus à la mairie de
beaune pour débattre de leurs
revendications et en particulier du riq
ce référendum d'initiative citoyenne
qu'il réclame qui sont qui sont en fait
donné par par les engloutit qui sont
élus à la fonction de président ne sont
pas respectées et ça c'est plus possible
parce que ça fait 40 ans que barak et
politiques d'une promet énormément
on n'a rien on est bafouée combat était
aujourd'hui nous tous on demande c -
carrick national pour pouvoir enfin
avoir une sécurité de le décider afin
d'avoir plus une démocratie
représentative et démocratie
suite au piège schiphol tous les projets
que nous menons que nous portons sont
fait en concertation en consultation
avec la population
une fois par mois les maires se rend
dans un quartier de la ville a été
découpée en dose grenot différentes et
une fois par mois là le maire se déplace
avec ses modèles pendant ces mois ont
pleuré on n'est pas rare qu'on ait ni
mort ni blessé
pour finir par se voir mais l'idée de ce
rendez vous c'est ma terre surtout reçu
contre c'est d'échanger sur les
différentes vont l'attendre de parler
chose vous vous portez des temps là est
tout à votre honneur
mais la consultation de la population
chacune des rencontres avec les élus des
territoires met en lumière toutes les
questions qui se posent au gilet jaune
comment se faire entendre sans désigner
de leader comment satisfaire chacune des
voix qui s'élèvent et comment maintenir
l'unité d'un mouvement spontané émouvant
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
la nouvelle démocratie directe à
laquelle ils aspirent tous est au coeur
des assemblées citoyennes qui en ce
printemps 2010 9 voit le jour en
bourgogne comme un peu partout en france
libéré sur les ronds-points la parole
commence à circuler d'une région à
l'autre à blanzy ce soir là on écoute
les propositions de saint nazaire où
vient de se tenir la deuxième assemblée
des assemblées celle amorce d'une
organisation nationale des gilet jaune
nous continuons à débattre nous
continuerons à nous battre contre toutes
deux en d'inégalité d'injustice de
discriminations et pour la solidarité
nous revendiquons l'augmentation
générale des salaires des retraites et
des militaires sous pour la liberté
l'égalité et la fraternité
notre solidarité et de lutte ou en tout
particulièrement en neuf millions de
personnes qui vivent sous lé seuil de
pauvreté
nous ne souhaitons pas une baisse des
dépenses publiques sans discernement
mais au contraire un maintien voire un
développement des services publics
services au public
nous sommes aujourd'hui plus forts et
plus déterminés que jamais a exigé une
vie digne pour tous aujourd'hui demain
et après demain
[Applaudissements]
l'esprit de solidarité et ce qui les
fait tenir
mais leur initiation à la politique
aucun d'entre eux n'en connaît l'issue
[Musique]
jusqu'à paris la route est encore longue
pour les marcheurs mais chez marie et
ses amis on va veiller tard dans la nuit
chaque étape qui passe révèle de
nouvelles amitiés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bébé
[Musique]
je sais pas
voilà
[Musique]
escargots de bourgogne
mais bon c'est sûr les bourguignons ont
un peu pousser les murs pour leurs hôtes
mais ensemble ils vont imaginer la suite
du combat
et puis se raconter les paysages et les
péripéties d'un voyage peu ordinaire
[Musique]
moi j'aime quand tu vas dormir ouais
cool partageant pas plus mal si mylène
champoux aller ah ouais franchement
j'avais mes chaussures
moi je n'avais jamais vécu quelque chose
de raser sur de pareils d'être sur la
route de se réapproprier en fait notre
territoire d'aller à la rencontre des
personnes et de parler autour d'une même
cause en fait d'échanger ensemble et de
se rendre et de faire preuve de
fraternité entre nous c'est super beau
on peut que les remercier de faire ce
qu'il faut parce que c'est vraiment
enfin voila vous fait que nous on ne
peut pas faire et vous lui faites du
coup de pas que pour vous le fait aussi
pour nous et pour tout le monde grâce à
vous en bas et aussi pas peut-être aussi
un peu grâce à lui que vous faites c'est
énorme pour tout le monde les
on espère en tout cas que voilà que les
gens se rendent compte vraiment du but
de votre démarche et de l'importance que
en tout cas que ça pourra apporter après
quoi ce que voilà ce qu'on fait on le
fait à notre petite échelle à nous ici à
beaune parce que bon on n'est vraiment
pas on est une petite ville de 23 mille
habitants ce qui est quand même enfin
voilà c'est pas on n'est pas un mari on
n'est pas a lille on n'est pas marseille
on n'est pas à lyon dont on essaie en
tout cas niveau être faire notre petit
combat comme ça ici le calme en moi dont
je suis tout avec mes trois enfants
parce que bon c'est un choix je les
choisis c'est comme ça bon je sais que
j'ai cumulé deux boulots pour pouvoir un
minimum vivre décemment et ce qui n'est
pas forcément encore évident tous les
jours parce que ben au 15 du mois on n'a
plus rien mais avec deux travaillent
quand on est seule avec trois enfants
parce que ben ils ont ils ont besoin au
quotidien des besoins financiers que ben
même en ayant deux je fais pas toujours
leur apporter donc moi je suis surtout
donc descendus dans la rue pour moi et
pour eux aussi parce que j'ai pas envie
que eux ils galèrent comme moi je peu
galéré maintenant pour ma maman qui a
soixante trois ans aussi qu' à la
retraite qui a repris le travail alors
qu'elle était à la retraite depuis un an
et je trouve pas une range france en
2019 c'est quand même pas normal ça se
passe encore comme ça que nous on est
des gens de la classe moyenne où on
bosse on serait vraiment les fesses pour
être poli au travail et pour vraiment
pour que ça marche et qu'au final à la
fin du mois dans la galère toujours
autant et qu'on n'a toujours pas plus
parce que mon gagnent trop pour avoir
des aides mais on gagne pas assez pour
vivre les simples donc au bout d'un
moment on est donc dans fin moi
personnellement je me retrouve un set
dans cette tranche moyenne où je mets 10
mais en fait il faut faire quoi pour
pouvoir s'en sortir quoi je ne peux plus
voir cette injustice en fait dans un
système en fait ce qui est un peu un
bout de souffle comme ça et tout ca
justice et le mouvement des jeunes c'est
vraiment ça en fait c'est toute une
population en fait qui existe up et qui
dit maintenant en fait ça suffit c'est
trop on est à bout et on veut un avenir
meilleur où quelque chose de meilleur
pour deux
[Musique]
alice au pays des merveilles
1 t 2 mars olala songe à alice coincé à
table entre ses hôtes le chapelier fou
et le lièvre de mars
je n'aurais jamais dû accepter cette
invitation lièvre de mars
roula les yeux en saisissant la théière
puis éclatant de rire servi le tas le
thé à ses amis attention avertit alice
vous visez à côté de la tasse et joyeux
anniversaire à vous rétro cas le
chapelier en soulevant son haut de forme
un ses points hauts de forme le chapeau
pour ses filles sabrina mène une
bataille quotidienne comme beaucoup de
mères qui élèvent seules leurs enfants
elles ne s'en sortiraient pas sans aide
alimentaire
donc on a des pattes
cette petite vache qui rit en quête des
céréales voilà votre contenter gamine
pâques devaient onecare ça c'est pas
très télé ma fille à son super bonne
ouais tiens toi ok merci
donc ça c'est les compotes donc on a de
la farine nous on n'a pas de ville non
et donc ils veulent arrêter l'aide
alimentaire j'ai pas vu les équipes qui
prend cette décision d'arrêter
l'état là par contre c'est pas quoi dire
j'ai choqué on est plus en plus dans le
besoin
il ya moins en moins de dead s'ils ne
suppriment ça va nous resterons de
gamins ou à merci à bientôt
merci beaucoup donc voilà
edwige moi et toi ok sabrina donc moi je
n'ai connu sur le rond point elle est
tout seul élève ses enfants elle a quand
même du mal à joindre les deux bouts
elle a pratiquement rien pour vivre
bon ben comme une gamine comme ça je te
dis oui ben moi il ya des fous que je
choisisse entre acheter des yaourts et
mettons vous prendre la voiture pour
pour emmener la gamine pour ic ce rendez
vous et tout et c'est vrai quel geek
mais mal des fois des yaourts et ben
c'est encore trop pour elle tu apprends
le chariot petit je regarde comme ça
c'est bon c'est bon alors alors nous
évidemment il ya temps en temps on fait
des petits repas là sur le rond point
donc ça permet des fois à ceux qui ne
mangent pas de viande bas de manger une
merguez ou un morceau de un morceau de
lard et tout dans un bout de pain eh ben
des fois je suis sûr que c'est le seul
morceau de viande que les jeunes sont la
semaine et ces femmes là elle trouve le
temps de se mobiliser moi je suis
stupéfaite
il ya vraiment un ras-le-bol vraiment
ras-le-bol
le combat de lydie sabrina et leurs
camarades c'est celui d'une population
qui veut relever la tête de cette france
périphérique marquée par la
désindustrialisation entre le creusot et
montceau les mines
quelques friche témoignent encore de
l'histoire du bassin minier qui fit la
renommée du territoire en perdant le
charbon les villes ont aussi perdu leur
industrie tandis que la crise opérette
une saignée silencieuse sur le monde
agricole
quarante années de décrochage et de
destructions d'emplois que les
développements du tertiaire et du
tourisme n'ont pas compensé
la fin du travail a fait le lit de bien
des désespoirs mais il a aussi nourri un
esprit de résistance au pied du chevalet
de mines qui se dressent encore à blanzy
les femmes et les hommes d'ici tente
d'écrire une nouvelle histoire
et puisque les actions sur les ronds
points sont désormais interdites le camp
du magny est devenu leur refuge ici on a
encore beaucoup de gens qui sont
retraités des mines dont beaucoup de
familles qui ont connu les mines qui ont
connu leurs parents aux mines et qui ont
connu les luttes sociales donc montceau
les mines à fédérer jusqu'à 2000
personnes sur le rond-point pour une
commune de 18000 habitants
je pense que si on fait le prorata par
rapport à beaucoup d'autres communes
c'est assez exceptionnel
le mouvement social tel qu'il existe
aujourd'hui était déjà pressenti depuis
très longtemps et aujourd'hui je pense
que c'est un mouvement qui traduit très
très bien le malaise social qui règne en
france depuis trop trop trop longtemps
pierre gaël a longtemps travaillé dans
une usine de céramique qui a fermé en
reconversion professionnelle
il est de ceux qui ont permis au camp du
manie de durée et à chacun de trouver sa
place la plomberie la maçonnerie les
animaux des enfants tout ce qui brille
connaît quoi bon on en avait un ou deux
là de maçon qui étaient avec nous aux
jets jaune on essaiera de les présenter
le temps use la mobilisation et les
violences qui se multiplient en ont
découragé plus d'un
mais les irréductibles des gilet jaune
se retrouvent ici chaque jour pour
discuter de leur avenir
je pense qu'on peut avoir bientôt un
vrai cahier de revendications complet
complet une plateforme numérique
nationale a mis en place c'est dans les
projets avec toutes les revendications
toutes les grandes actions nationales et
européennes chez n'y a pas de raison le
réseau qu'on a créé de gilet jaune
maintenant qu'il est créé on est tous
capables de se fédérer même si on se
perd de vue pendant trois mois six mois
on est tous capable de surfer mais moi
je suis confiant on va aboutir on va
aboutir à quelque chose
la suite je sais pas moi je m'étais pas
imaginé qu'on allait révolutionner la
france en trois semaines
peut-être qu'un certain nombre de gens
l'avaient cru mais de toute façon un
combat social comme celui là ça ne
pouvait que durer très longtemps ce qui
a été un vrai frein en mouvement dès
gilet jaune ça a été sa capacité à
s'organiser à se constituer à se fédérer
et à pouvoir mettre en place des
référents des porte paroles on les
appellera comme on voudra mais des gens
qui puissent aller discuter avec le
gouvernement
2 qu'est ce qui se passe en fait en
france parce qu'on a toujours à faire
une classe dirigeante qui est
complètement déconnectés de notre vie
réelle
comme ça apprenti la mineure je crois
[Musique]
tout au long du canal du centre qui
rythmaient jadis l'activité du bassin
houiller les quartiers ouvriers ont
perdu leur café leur petit commerce et
leur jeunesse à mesure qu'un
déclassement massif gagner les classes
populaires et les classes moyennes
le chômage et le repli sur soi ronge les
âmes et à quelques kilomètres seulement
des centres villes les habitants se
sentent abandonnés bon il fait pas moi
m'a finalement aujourd'hui nous annonce
un candidat du mas un petit bout de
temps déjà les mois la banque de vos
soucis seront normalement
bon alors que 9 minutes a eu une fille
oh oui c'était bien bon alors qu'il est
les gens étaient intéressés pour le
bistrot là pour maman tout fait pour ta
vente l'appareil était intéressant
oui oui toi d'intéresser tout en plus il
n'avait leaf on new as well as la banque
ouais mais bon c'est le propriétaire qui
coince ils veulent quoi faire de trois
volets la merde
or espérons que les autres ça va ce qui
va sauver leur à l'europe
leurs empreintes mais parce que ce
samedi donc si on a plus ça nous qu'est
ce qu'on fait tu peux faire le siège
social des gilets jaunes garicoix de
juger l'accusé jugé dès jeudi déjà les
jours de 8 yards rouge au cul je vais
appeler gilet jaune on va s'installer là
que va faire un café un café planète il
ya plus futés maire de saint paul avec
trois ans de cotisation je vais m'en
aller avec 875 euros
donc ça fait pas trop ce que ça donne
vous rendre à leur école c'est pareil tu
vois moi personnellement j'ai un gros
smic tous les ouates charges sociales
alors quand on arrive à descendre comme
ça c'est pas possible ça t'a mis les
charges sont en cours avec une voiture
qui s'est quand même des frais pour la
com - ici sont a pas de voitures pas
foutu mais bon après quand je vois une
en retraite genre quoi 800 900 euros par
mois à 800 euros 2 0 juste t/t charge
pour te loger c'est toi
il ya beaucoup de misère quoi finalement
de plus en plus un agriculteur je pense
tout seul ne peut plus faire vivre une
famille de toute façon assez claire
et puis ben beaucoup de gens traités et
tout pour qui je travaille c'est pareil
il compte tout quoi il compte tout je
vois les petits commerçants aussi les
charges qu enfin il me semble que depuis
des années on le dit mais je pense qu'il
ya du boulot les artisans tout seuls n'y
arrivent plus elle la petite la
coiffeuse à la prime apprentis mais elle
dit c'est vachement dur quand elle dit
qu'elle se soit plus de salaire
maintenant pratiquement alors que alors
qu'elle prend une petite elle essaye
d'aller dans le bon sens de prendre une
apprentie parce qu'on sait que ça dure
ils veulent relancer l'apprentissage ne
faut déjà que les patrons puissent les
prendre des apprentis faudrait déjà
qu'ils puissent les payer s'ils peuvent
déjà pas sortir de saleh il faut pas
sortir un salaire pour un apprentissage
veut dire des fonds marche sur la tête
ils veulent faire des choses qui sont
très bien mais ils font tout l'inversé
de ce que fâche pas là où les politiques
qui fâche pas faudrait qu'ils descendent
et puis je pense qu'il se transforme
temps en temps monsieur tout le monde
qui regarde vraiment voir ce qui se
passe réellement quoi je voudrais bien
mais que comme ils vont installer la
cuisine la du mois là c'est donner un
petit coup là sur la tapisserie qu'est
lavables son combat liddy le même chaque
jour auprès des personnes âgées chez qui
elle travaille à domicile
ou plus fragiles et à ceux qui sont
isolés elle consacre tout son temps et
les faïences il voulait laisse on a plus
de service public
nous jouons marman à la pause c'est que
le matin et puis c'est un service
communal
je veux dire il ya plein de petites
communes coupe le lien qu'on plus
d'écoles comme une comme ça commence a
pu entendre les gamins brailler lac ou
dans la cour quand tu vas acheter ton
pas au togo c'est déjà ce diamant
pourquoi j'ai entendu aussi fermé de
maisons de retraite n'a dans une autre
commune oui quand même beaucoup de
choses qui que quand tu regardes bien tu
te dis mais où on va quoi que que toi
[Musique]
personne sait où vont les petits corps
doit on à l'instant c'est le flou c'est
le flou et deux écoles qui ferment les
toitures maintenant il supprime tous les
bénévoles se fermer l'hôpital
il supprime une école académie dit que
c'est le maire qui prend la décision le
maire nous a dit que c'est l'académie
on va fermer une école au centre ville
oui là l'école du centre ville c'est la
deuxième c'est celle là qui nous ferment
aussi centre-ville en train de mourir ah
oui moi je vis mon chat n'a dans les
années 2000 je peux vous dire que ça va
il y avait beaucoup plus d'activité que
sa mort dix enfants sont ni à l'école la
les paul et jean de la fontaine et ça je
suis arrivée là que j'ai vu que jean de
la fontaine était fermée et qu'on
parlait de fermer là
ça tue centre-ville tu le boulot aussi
ça tue le travail on n'allait pas
marcher sur le marché en sortant de
l'école
c'est quand même dur de vivre la
campagne
comment ne pas céder à la fatalité et
comment réparer ce que les crises
successives ont emporté au pied des
monts du charolais les gens du pays
minier veulent encore croire que leur
combat sauvera leur école leur petit
commerce et les services publics
[Musique]
à l'entrée de l'été sabrina lydie et
leurs camarades de saône et loire sont
sur le qui vive
comme tous les samedis ils se retrouvent
sur un talus du rond-point interdit à
l'entrée de montchanin
mais aujourd'hui ils attendent la
confirmation d'une nouvelle importante
il serait favori pour organiser la
prochaine assemblée des assemblées pour
la troisième fois les gilet jaune venus
de tous les départements ont prévu de se
retrouver dans un rassemblement national
l'enjeu est de parvenir à réinventer le
mouvement pour devenir une véritable
force politique et citoyenne
la semaine dernière on avait demandé un
vote sur le fait de présenter notre
candidature pour l'organisation de la
prochaine assemblée des assemblées
alors il y avait paris qui avait voulu
se présenter par contre ça va être
tellement non
unanimité que du coup ils ont pas voulu
alors ça on a trouvé ça bien le fait que
vraiment les gens se mobilisent pour pas
que ce soit encore quelque chose qui se
passe à paris donc il restait
montpellier et nous donc entre toutes
les actions le fait qu'on soit quand
même toujours mobilisés même si nous ça
nous paraît peu même si on sait qu'aux
assemblées en a moins de monde que
pendant un moment
eh ben on est dans la haute sphère du
nombre de personnes qui viennent aux
assemblées donc à la grande majorité on
a remporté pour faire la prochaine
assemblée des assemblées
donc voila moi c'est une grande fierté
ça veut dire nourriture matin midi et
soir pour 1000 personnes
si on emile plus nous tous qui seront à
la logistique
on verra les solutions tous ensemble
ce rassemblement qui arrive est un
rendez vous crucial pour l'avenir du
mouvement
car au fil des mois beaucoup de gilet
jaune ont eu peur se sont lassés ou
déchirés fanny et ses camarades du magny
vont devoir remobiliser les troupes et
travailler à l'organisation de débats
constructifs
ce qui ressort beaucoup au niveau du
mouvement
c'est un passage à la 6ème république
donc si vraiment on reprend tout la
constitution telle qu'elle est faite la
cinquième a arrêté l est pas compliqué
le problème c'est la transition pour
arriver à la 6e et comment on met en
place la sixième
donc je veux dire ça c'est quelque chose
qui ressort beaucoup beaucoup au niveau
national sur lesquels plein plein de
gens travaillent pareil travailler
chacun dans leur coin et on est en train
de vraiment se rejoindre pour arriver à
un médecin en place au niveau national
donc ça ça va prendre aussi encore du
temps
[Applaudissements]
trois mois ont passé
sur le stade et dans le gymnase prêté
par la mairie de montceau les mines
des représentants des gilet jaune sont
venus de toute la france
[Applaudissements]
pendant deux jours ils vont travailler
et essayer d'imaginer ensemble l'avenir
du mouvement sans environ entre délégués
et observateurs 650 personnes qui
viennent vraiment de toute la france
d'ailleurs il ya une carte de france où
vous pouvez épinglé une petite aiguille
pour savoir d'où vous venez ça nous re
visuellement ça représente encore plus
nous retransmettons en direct sur
youtube facebook switch et à l'extérieur
on va déjà parlé pour aujourd'hui après
cette séance donc vous avez des boîtes
là qu'ils sont en train de circuler pour
les tirages au sort des du premier round
des axes donc au niveau des accents 1 on
a le référendum d'initiative partagée en
deux on a doit t'on et où peut-on sortir
du capitalisme en trois les assemblées
citoyennes locales en 4 occuper le
terrain en 5
les assemblées des assemblées et en 6
les convergences nous on voudrait qu'il
en ressorte des actions on voudrait
qu'il ya des dates bien précises
quand on ressort tous de nos de nos
groupes de travail fdt a surtout du
groupe action et qui est des choses
auxquelles on se tiennent tous
tout le week end les ateliers de travail
vont se succéder
sabrina a été choisi par ses camarades
du rond point jeanne rose pour les
représenter c'est sa première
participation à un rassemblement
national
personne n'a vu yanis vous avez pas vu
gagner gagner
lydie fait partie des bénévoles qui
assurent la logistique du week end
il ya plus de papier dans les bleus
larvaires faire le trou avec azur notre
fils que nous dire est qu'il faut encore
des toiles qui sont très bons je vais
aller bon toute façon tant d'efforts
ouais je vais faire un tour
puis j'ai regardé autre côté le vab
aussi faire un tour
c'est vraiment inédit comme un mouvement
très bien et ça marche tu as des gens
qui viennent
downeast à des gens de saint nazaire
taddeo jean denant site à des hordes les
gens de vendée à des gens partout dans
toute la france de toulouse et ou qui
sont là des artisans tu as des gens qui
travaillent en usine
tu as des commerçants qui a vraiment
toutes les personnes représentées au
niveau national quoi et c'est ça qui est
important parce qu'on se voit que chacun
dans notre petit coin on faisait pour
l'instant où allah et tout parce qu'en
plus on est français dont on pourra dire
chorale voilà c'est normal mais chacun
raleigh dans son petit coin et là tout
d'un coup ça fait un tout le monde s'est
regroupé tous et puis on peut poser sur
la table des problèmes nationaux et
régionaux même dans l'atelier de sabrina
cette première matinée de débats est
consacrée à la défense des services
publics avec une priorité le référendum
sur la privatisation d'aéroports de
paris
alors moi je suis peut être initiée au
sujet
mais sur la question de l'aéroport de
paris je sais pas trop ce que ça engage
à privatisation
si ce n'est qu'il ya une forme de
deux prélèvements de capital qui va au
privé et donc ce qui va au désavantage
du bien commun la privatisation
des aéroports de paris ça va servir
toujours les mêmes choses les mêmes
intérêts c'est à dire les actionnaires
qui va y avoir de toute manière tous les
grands groupes veulent s'accaparer tout
ce qui a de la valeur et qui nous
appartient qui a été payé par nos impôts
alors qu'on nous dit il faut que les
services publics dégage des bénéfices
phoque l'hôpital dégage des bénéfices là
pour une fois qu'on a aussi un service
public qui dégage des bénéfices
on veut le vendre privé aujourd'hui
c'est les aéroports demain ça va être
les forêts ça va être les routes ça va
être dur etc
si on arrive à avoir les 4 millions 700
mille signatures de la pétition et que
si le rythme est organisé comme il faut
ça va donner un coup d'arrêt à beaucoup
de choses ya plusieurs sujets qui ont
commandé des tracts et des affiches afin
de donc les affiches distribuées dans
l'est dans les commerces boulangeries
cafés magasins
moi je veux
me demande plutôt c'est le niveau
explications parce que les gens quand on
donne les papiers sont pas envie de lire
les gens de maintenance tout le temps
derrière les écrans dont peut-être je ne
sais pas je propose une idée faire une
vidéo avec des personnes qui connaissent
bien le principe avec des packs des mots
trop compliqué trop compliqué quoi
expliquer le problème de l'aéroport
expliqué pourquoi il faut signer cette
pétition pourquoi voilà en vidéo c'est
peut-être qu'on peut faire quelque chose
de national qui serait qu'ils seraient
audible par tout le monde
les changes qui a eu est vachement
intéressant ça m'a redonné le lan de
continuer ça m'a donné l'espoir que
j'avais commencé à perdre tout sens une
responsabilité oui
la responsabilité de faire montrer aux
femmes qu'on a on a un pouvoir quand
même on a une force
on est tellement rabaisser dans tous les
domaines que des femmes qu'elles
comprennent qu'elles sont fortes on a
une force en nous - la force je la tiens
de mes enfants et on a tous un but dans
la vie on a tous une motivation dans la
vie il faut juste la trouver il faut que
chacun surtout s'écouter et puis en
tirent profit
je pense que c'est par là que le travail
va plus se faire ça après quand les gens
iront à wez suicide moi la première
celui-ci la distance celui-là il a dit
ça avec moi je voyais pas comme ça mais
il a apporté quelque chose en plus qui
avait c'est le petit truc que j'avais
pas pensé du tout et là ça ouvre
l'esprit quoi et ça c'est vachement
intéressant ça m'ouvre ça ouvre l'esprit
je trouve que pour ça s'est super bien
boire d'un atelier à l'autre les débats
ont été vifs entre les partisans d'un
affrontement musclé avec le gouvernement
et ceux qui prônent la négociation
l'avenir est bien incertain et le
consensus difficile à trouver
désigner des leaders restent une
épineuse question pour le mouvement
durant tout le week end le collectif a
été mise à rude épreuve mais sur la
terre de bourgogne un arbre étrangers
symbolique a fait l'unanimité
sur ses branches les gilet jaune et les
militants pour le climat ont accroché
leurs revendications communes
des dizaines de rubans promettent la
convergence des luttes pour défendre la
planète et combattre les inégalités
sociales
[Musique]
on comprend qu'ils vous recommencez un
petit peu au début pourquoi pour
expliquer aux personnes qui s'y
intéressaient pas du tout le pourquoi du
comment
pourquoi on a commencé les jets jaune
pourquoi on est là on est pas là parce
qu'on s'ennuie on est là parce qu'on en
a marre on est là parce qu on a faim on
est là parce qu'on veut avoir un
restaurant un livre
[Musique]
elle est où ton espérance toi pas que
tout le monde puisse vivre tout le monde
puisse avoir du boulot pour que et puis
avec leur travail qu'ils puissent vivre
qui puisse mettre de l'essence qui
puisse nourrir les monde qui puisse
emmener au moins une fois dans l'année
leurs mômes en vacances
moi j'aime également par exemple que 25
et 30 31 ans qui me disent au bonheur
des mômes je peux enfin j'ai mon fils
bien sûr c'est pour élever mon môme et
puis rien pouvoir qu'ils profitent pas
de laver toujours mieux quoi en faire
enfin à 25 ans je veux dire les gamins
et j'en parlais des sens avec des mamans
et tout comme moi et il ya plein de
mouvements qui sont dans cette idée là
ne pas faire d'enfant parce qu'ils
savent pas ce que l'avenir leur réserve
j'ai envie de changer le monde je sais
que j'y arriverai pas tout
j'espère pouvoir changer quelques petits
trucs
[Musique]